since we've wrapped I haven't seen a lot
of their faces so a lot has happened and
there's babies and marriages and I just
can't wait to catch up you know where
the zoo
good to see you virtually you look
amazing oh do you you look so good
middle my day oh how are we doing right
now with everything girl yeah well right
before I got on this call I just read
that stay at home got extended until
August so I'm digesting that you take it
day by day
and I think that some days are harder
for others and I have to keep in
perspective like I'm just grateful I
have sunshine I have my dog it's been a
little hard doing it alone like we as
humans we need human connection and so I
think I'm feeling a little I think we're
all feeling it at this point but um
staying optimistic eating a lot of crap
food and yeah watching a lot of TV while
times that we're living in I do want to
talk about Katy keno this entire season
was such a fun watch it doesn't mean
that it's wrong have I lost you I feel
like I've lost me
the world who you are can we get a tease
for the finale what can fans expect yes
well there's a lot going on we have like
a huge realization from Katie that she's
still in love with someone and so she's
chasing after that she also was like
getting her revenge on guy with a really
spectacular show and then we have like a
potential dad that comes into play we
feel like we might meet who Katie's dad
is which is huge because that's what a
lot of the series has been about and
then what else oh and then I get to sing
I get to sing one of my favorite songs
of all time so it's a little bit of
everything going on like what if I would
have said yes to Kayla's proposal
something else that I do have to talk to
you about Friday
pretty little reunion and it's for a
good cause which is what I love I think
it's for feeding America right yeah so
all proceeds raised from from Friday's
event will go to feeding America and
it's it's really cool it's it's called
cast for good I'm just massively
impressed that they are getting all of
us all of us are gonna be there I
believe and it'll be the first time all
of us have it we won't physically be in
the same place but since we've wrapped I
haven't seen a lot of their faces so a
lot has happened and there's babies and
marriages and I just can't wait to catch
up and and do it all along with everyone
watching and like you said such an
amazing cause and yeah I'm looking
creaking how did this come about like
who reached out to who whose idea sort
of catapulted this into existence so I
know that Tyler Blackburn did something
similar with his Roswell cast and a
friend of mine
Todd Krim he kind of he what he does is
he sets up celebrities with charities he
emailed Marlene King our showrunner
Marlene send an email down the email
chain and we were all like yeah yeah I
mean not where none of us are doing
anything right now so we have no excuse
not to but it was yeah like no brainer
for all of us
the fans are gonna be able to ask you
guys any questions about pol Lu is there
certain question that you hope to get
asked I feel like at this point I feel
like it doesn't what I've been asked
every form of PLL question ever yeah but
people are getting really creative so
I'm curious to see to see what they come
up with hopefully something that I
haven't been asked before well does this
Reese Park conversations about a
possible movie ever in the future you
know I I have heard and I feel like I
mean look we're we're in a quarantine
that we thought would last a couple of
weeks like anything is possible at this
point like I don't rule anything out
I feel like we need a little more time
to pass I feel like if we would get more
out of it if we were like 10 years down
the road although I feel like they're
gonna do a spin-off or something before
then I don't know I'm so protective of
the show so I feel like when when the
time comes if they want to like do it
with a whole new cast like I might have
to produce it because I'm Way too
protective of it but I know you haven't
seen a lot of them what are you most
excited about for Friday oh man it'll
just be good to like connect with people
I just want to have conversations I mean
not only with with people I haven't seen
in two years but all the fans that are
calling in I think it's just gonna be
like a lot of positive energy and a lot
of love and hopefully we can just
distract each other for however I think
it's a couple hours so hopefully we can
just have a good time and and kind of
forget about everything for a second and
just check in with everybody I love that
where would aria and Ezra be at this
point maybe like important life I feel
like they would be quarantine anyway
they were so strange like I feel like
they would be in a cabin just alone
anyway yeah I just have these they were
always like an old married couple even
when they were young so we were yeah
they're knitting and having tea and I
don't know what else if they're doing
[Music]